do that don't know nice that's how I get
in bed every time I like the belt I like
the reverse I think I just broke the bed
[Music]
hey what's up I'm Alex some Jack we are
the better-looking half of all-time low
and we were here at tasty to enjoy some
tasty treats oh my oh let's go correct
answer to the best breakfast ever
is chicken and waffles yeah I'm very
excited oh my gosh offer a blister bun
that's maybe one of the better fried
chickens I've had in my life so off
camera chef wherever you are let's have
some questions we got some questions
here in the bowl every morning I eat
breakfast there's always a bowl of
questions next to me what to challenge
the mind how often do you eat this for
breakfast chicken and waffles is not
something I have often but it's
something I really really enjoy so I
like to spread it out when I do get to
have it it's like a nice treat I picked
waffles with strawberries because I'm
really healthy guy you know I got a
strawberries in there the vitamin B what
kind of vitamins are in strawberries I
look this up latter-day vitamin ass what
were your favorite breakfast foods
growing up that's a good one I used to
get those on the cinnamon Eggos I'm
gonna do that thing they do on TV where
they like pretend to cut the food to
make it look like you're busy keep
talking just act natural and answer the
question I used to take cinnamon Eggo
waffles and put sausage and cheese in
between them wow you're a little little
chef clarity for the arable parents let
me knew that this batter though got
really good that's all on the mic I hope
they turn that way up you're a savage
there's two chicken we'll take a woman
what foods remind you of home my mom
always made this isn't really breakfast
but my mama always made really good
spaghetti bolognaise really so Bolognese
is like such a comfort food in general
and my mom's was particularly good I'm
getting cooler from the chicken I'm not
mad about Oh
alright Here I am Here I am judging it's
all good don't do it I didn't think it
would be good you okay
chew through it have another straw
refreshing who's the better cook between
the two of us I mean I literally can't
cook I can't I can't go except I can
you're a really good cook I get it from
my mama what's a food you hate a food
that I hate I don't wait we like a lot
of stuff yeah I try not very picky I
like to keep an open mind and an open
palette oh this is a good one for you
Jack um we have it I'll give you that
okay I'm ready
what are your must-haves snacks on tour
and backstage mmm watch that name for me
man cuz you last tour you ate a box of
pistachios every day of a snacker I was
going through a pistachio phase I've had
probably 20 pistachios in my entire life
before the last tour and then now there
is a pistachio crisis there's a
pistachio tree growing in my body his
wife what's the one food people have to
try from your hometown oh we're from
Baltimore yeah I mean crabs that's that
would be the simple one a good crab cake
there's Rams in everything yeah it
macaroni and cheese pizza burgers like
pretzels they have these things called
ah are they called there's like a crab
pretzel oh yeah yeah yeah yeah basically
just like this big pretzel and they put
crab on it and cheese old bay awesome
even though I'm eating I'm getting
hungry what are some of your favorite
cities to eat in with the best food blue
food stays um I like the south I like
like Texas and all the southern cities I
like even barbecue Austin Austin Austin
is good for barbecue Kansas yes
Kansas BBQ is really good Boston lobster
roll yes
we're talking lobster roll Tom la la has
everything la is such a good melting pot
of food and we live here so we know on
the spots what city are you most excited
to see this summer I'm pretty pumped to
play Maryland it's been a little while
since we played Baltimore and our
hometown
we're playing outdoors at the pier it's
gonna be amazing what about you my
favorite city okay
can't say Maryland because that's what
you said right
I'm gonna say Lollapalooza Chicago yeah
we've never played Lollapalooza that's
gonna be really cool very excited yeah
thank you for the breakfast in bed tasty
this was amazing I'm shy once the
cameras stopped rolling this thing will
disappear I'm gonna do that thing they
do on food food shows anyway I have more
food to eat now we'll see you next time
[Music]
she's coming back to childhood right now
all right I can't get out of it
[Music]